so just like when we started off
understanding for snacking
I'm gonna give you the simplest one I
can so I want you to say for example if
you are told there is an object it's
moving with uniform circular motion
okay the radius of this circular motion
is two meters and it's rotating at 80
revolutions per minute 80 revolutions
per minute okay I'll ask you three
questions of this some obvious object
mm-hmm firstly can you tell me can you
tell me what a maker is can you tell me
what became dealer velocity is equal to
just by convention because we're in
calculus land you're obviously going to
be using radians not doing these also by
convention just forget how quickly this
is happening let's do it in seconds
right so let's go in radians per second
can you answer in that form that's the
first thing I want you know secondly can
you tell me let me hear you told me to
speak tell me the speed based on this
idea over here how is actually changing
distance over time not just the angle
and lastly can you tell me what's the
period of motion
now we're used to hearing this idea of
period with arm you know trig functions
with simple harmonic motion okay
remember if I gave you a key function
like this what's the period of the sine
curve the regular thank you so what we
mean what the word period means is how
long does it take to go through one
complete movement and then you're better
to start when you met this stuff so just
say what's the period of motion is how
long does it take me to go from one
position right so this is like that
person up on the edge do you go all the
way around and back to their beginning
in other words the time for one whole
rotation okay so three simple questions
here's all the information and there's
all the data that you need a precious
small amount can you have a gun I'll
give you two minutes to do okay all
right let me just quickly show you
there's only three questions three
simple and
see how you win okay thank you well good
okay so firstly just angular velocity
okay now angular velocity all of this
was actually just a conversion right
because you noticed radians per second
right you've been told revolutions per
minute right now those are thus they're
measuring the same thing revolutions and
radians it's just a matter of scale and
seconds minutes it's just a matter of
scale them it's measuring the same units
okay
so therefore what you say is Omega Omega
is any revolutions per minute but that's
no good for radians per second right so
I'm going to say 80 now what's a
revolution in terms of radians
the answer is 2pi that's how many
radians I've moved through in how long
one minute which is 60 seconds right
does that make sense
now please note there's no radius
involved no radius involved right
because no matter where I am you have
one which person I am the whole body
stills the same angular velocity does
that make sense
Susan you don't need the radius to know
what the velocity is
can we just simplify this out what you
end up with cancel cancel that's sixteen
on six so that's a PlayOn three egg time
on three let's just quickly do be in
seeing them you can heat up so there's a
parent of radians per second for Part B
excuse me to make out speed you can do
it from first principles if you like but
you can see here the velocity has to be
0 excuse me
angular velocity and the proportion is
just the radius which is 2 right so I
can say let's call this V V is absorbed
or from scratch is DL or DT where L is
awkward
you might have just a briefing to find
that but L is just going to be two feet
up right that's the derivative of 2
theta ok so that's 2 times there's
defeater oddity in there so that's 2
times Omega so there's 16 pi on 3 what
yeah you can that's fine
but I still want you to be able to do it
this way so what should be able to do
this way
lastly period of mission you've got two
ways you can do this okay firstly you
can go back to 80 revolutions per minute
80 revolutions per minute so if I can do
this is a period right I tried to say 80
revolutions per 60 seconds
remember we defined a period of motion
as how long it takes to go one full
revolution my muscle revolution I'll
have a simple answer okay so if I've got
this here right
eight revolutions 60 seconds I just want
one revolution so what I do to the top
and bottom to turn this into one
revolution necessary such as the ratio
of two quantities right 80 revolution
seek the second 60 seconds a revolution
don't matter I'm just gonna divide by
eight right so if you divide this by any
you divide this by 80 right so that's
going to give me one revolution on the
top that's how long that's how far would
it go and 60 180 I believe is
three-quarters of a second right so
therefore the period of motion is just a
second right which is quite nothing
think it must be three quarters it has
to be three quarters combat it can take
more than a second why not
because in 60 seconds you're calling
more revolutions per minute right so
you're doing more than one full
revolution per second right so that's
why they took that you wonderful ok
there's one other way of doing this
do you remember if you have something
exciting 3x right how would you work out
what's one quick way of wonder what the
period of version is you'd say well
there's a 2pi divided by whatever
whatever that guy use right that's how
many times you go through so in the same
way I can use this guy no sorry
Skype you this is the angular once this
is how far I go perceptive all have to
do is dude soup I on a boundary in the
same way that I did here which looks to
me like six PI on 8 pi which is still
3/4 over sin okay so I know this is fine
2 pi Omega that will give you the period
of mission which is a nice general
result or if you have it in revolutions
let's just change the ratio okay